the president of the a.a edmund king
edmond lovely to see you um
so let's start with a very
straightforward question what do you
make of it is it a good idea that we
have these health checks in our cars not
every one year but every two the
government has raised this before justin
greening in 2011 jesse norman in 2018
and on both occasions changing the mot
was actually ruled out on safety grounds
and it is very important if you look at
mot failures it is things like lighting
suspension and brakes one in six of the
failures in the last quarter were about
breaks now obviously getting your brakes
checked once a year is very important
for safety
and when we've polled aaa members 94
think the mot is either very important
or quite important for safety so no
overall on safety grounds
on money grounds and indeed
environmental grounds the mot also
checks car emissions and if you've got a
gross polluter out there pumping out
lots of diesel emissions etc that will
be picked up at the mot and put right so
i guess on all those grounds it's really
not the best solution
i mean edmund you and i both know that
motor insurers have their customers best
interests at heart all of the time maybe
i'm just wondering what they might
respond to seeing mots going from one
year to two years i mean it's going to
see an increase in the premiums isn't it
well i think it could because basically
if you've got cars with faulty brakes
out there they are more likely to have
the collision
and premiums are based on likelihood of
collisions and therefore it could
actually put it up
but i think the other thing in term in
terms of cost savings you know how many
cars do you see out there with one
faulty headlight or a rear light out or
a brake light out
and that things like that get picked up
at the mot
if you get stopped by the police the
fixed penalty notice for that offense is
a hundred pounds if you don't put it
right it goes up to a thousand pounds
so again the cost of a fixed penalty is
twice as much just about as the cost of
an mot so it doesn't really save you
money there
so i think you know what what we'd say
to the government there are other ways
you could help drivers and yes the
chancellor did in in the last mini
budget cut fuel duty by 5p elite
um to save that extra 55 pounds a year
he could cut fuel duty by another couple
of uh pence and the chancellor's still
getting more money in because of the
high cost of fuel he's getting the 20
v80 and v80 comes on the overall pump
price
so the customer the the chancellor is
still making more money from that v80 so
there still is a bit of wiggle room for
the government to do it without
potentially overall costing them more
money and that would be appreciated a
lot more by many many drivers out there
who are finding it very tough at the
moment whilst the majority actually
support an annual mot for safety reasons
for themselves and others